as previously announced students were
set to return to the classroom on
january 10th
following an extended winter break
today we are announcing a one-week
remote learning period beyond january
10th to help ensure schools
can implement enhanced measures
for the safe return of in-person
learning
we know that our youth learn best in a
classroom setting it is our goal to
ensure they can return to the classroom
as quickly as possible
with that i'll pass it over to minister
cullen to provide further details on the
announcement today
on december 22nd our government made the
announcement to extend winter break
until january 10th
today we are announcing a phased-in
approach
for return to school in january
and are shifting to a one-week remote
learning period
for most students after the holiday
break
this phased-in approach
will allow school divisions and schools
to have more time to prepare operational
plans
including planning for potential
staffing shortages
and expected absenteeism due to
isolation requirements
discussions with manitoba education's
response planning team have reinforced
the importance of this extra time to
plan for a return to class as soon as
possible
this planning team has been in place
since march of 2020 and it includes the
manitoba association of school
superintendents
the manitoba school board association
the manitoba association of school board
officials
the manitoba teachers society
manitoba federation of independent
schools
and public health officials
this will ensure public health officials
have more time to assess the effects of
the omicron byron
effective january 10th this phased-in
approach will allow students of critical
service workers in kindergarten to grade
six
and at-risk students and students with
special learning needs in kindergarten
to grade 12 to attend school
before and after child care programs
will remain open for students of
critical service workers and students
with special needs who are attending
school this week
all other students will learn remotely
until they return on january 17th
this extra week of remote learning will
provide time for distribution of
additional masks and rapid tests to
schools across the province
access to rapid tests for all manitobans
will be expanded
as the rapid testing kit supply
increases here in manitoba
particularly for schools with high case
counts of the covet 19.
we will also be distributing more than 5
million additional child and adult
medical masks over the next eight weeks
to increase existing supply in schools
this time will also provide teachers and
those over 18 who are eligible to get
their booster shots and students five
and up
to get their second dose
to improve accessibility and increase
immunization rates after our
school-based clinics will continue
for students
for staff and community members
our government recognizes there are
financial pressures
related to wage agreements for teachers
as well as the ongoing impact of covet
19.
today we are also announcing an
investment of up to 80 million dollars
in new funding for manitoba schools
for the 21
22 year
today's investment will ensure our
school system is supported particularly
during covet
manitoba has exceptional teachers school
staff and leaders committed to ensuring
students
reach their full potential
our investment will enable schools to
continue providing high quality learning
for all manitoba students
with today's funding announcement
our government has invested an
additional
200 million dollars for school
operations this year alone
this includes
45 million for a two percent property
tax offset grant
paid directly to school divisions
we've also increased the operating
budget for schools
this year to date we have invested 63
million to support the covet response
i will say that manitoba has one of the
highest per-pupil covet funding
allocation in canada to date
over 330 dollars per pupil
almost half of this allocation is going
directly into the classroom to support
additional teachers and educational
assistants
the remainder is being used to fund
health and safety measures
ventilation upgrades remote learning
masks and personal protective equipment